foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight appears Morgan uncensored
it was terrifying to have my brother
Scream and Shout at me and my father say
things that just simply weren't true and
and my grandmother you know quietly sit
there and sort of Take It All In
foreign
Prince Harry further torches his Royal
relations for the blistering attack on
the British Monarchy and deeply personal
incendiary claims about his own family
Buckingham Palace remains dignified in
his silence about the Netflix Fallout
the senior also might presented the
united front at a charity Carroll
service the big question now is how much
damage will this series inflate on the
monarchy and Britain's image across the
world
also tonight tens of thousands of nurses
striking the biggest walkout in the
history of the NHS one of the nurses who
saved Boris Johnson's life is now
striking and she's here exclusively to
tell me why
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on censored today Harry and
Megan taught what little was left of
their relationship with the royal family
and what little was left frankly of
their own reputations last week was
mostly sycophantic this latest
installment was downright seditious
Prince Harry mauls his own brother
accuses his father the new king of being
a liar even as a dig in his late great
grandmother the Queen the standing by
and doing nothing
the royal family is directly accused of
destroying two of its own to protect
itself
and I don't know where it all stops all
this
where does it end we got the book and
then we've got the interview circuit and
until it goes on
it's all apparently a dark plot by
Britain and the Royals to smear the poor
defenseless vulnerable sussexes
trickery treachery hypocrisy and if
there's one conclusion to draw from the
final installment of their Netflix
series it's the Prince Harry surely as
now a traitor to the country that he
once served
William and I both saw what happened in
our in our dad's office
and we made an agreement that we would
never let that happen to our office and
just see my brother's office copy the
very same thing that we promised the two
of us would never ever do
that was heartbreaking it was terrifying
to have my brother um Scream and Shout
at me and my father say things that just
simply weren't true and and my
grandmother you know quietly sit there
and sort of take it all in they're happy
to lie to protect my brother
and yet for three years they were never
willing to tell the truth to protect us
unbelievable it's blistering attack not
only on the institution of the monarchy
but also personally against the senior
Royals who represent our country around
the world is in my view Beyond contempt
in their selfish vaping attempts to
rewrite history recasting themselves as
victims these two have sold their souls
and they sold Harry's family down the
river it's unforgivable and it would
leave a bitter taste in the mouths of
millions of people but there are toe
curling moments in this show too moments
that upset even the strongest of
stomachs
if you
viewers are force-fed simpering clips of
the pair frolicking on Californian
beaches during covid in Tyler Perry's
mansion no less While most people were
locked down many in tiny homes with lots
of children
but they were the real victims not the
thousands of people dying from a new
pandemic virus
they again cry foul of course at the
beastly horrible media for pursuing them
and wanting to take their pictures
whilst persistently throughout this new
installment showing their own highly
intrusive pictures of their own children
did they ask permission from those
children to invade their privacy for
money which is of course the very
challenge they make against the media we
also learned that Megan actually thinks
she's done Britain a favor
we get on the plane
and it's not the pilot but whoever is
sort of overseeing the crew
and he came
and he knelt next to my seat and he took
his hat off
and I remember looking at him he goes
appreciate everything you did for our
country
and it was the first time that I felt
like someone
saw the sacrifice
not from my own country
for this country it's not mine
sacrifice is that a joke
a sacrifice
who was this guy
who was this cabin Steward does he exist
or is he like the last one you met you
remember the Lion King premiere you told
you what a hero you were we couldn't
find him can we will we find this cabin
Steward who apparently knelt
and took his hat off in respect for this
awesome woman who'd sacrificed so much
for our country that she's actually
caused so much damage to I'd like to
know that person exists well it was just
one of the cabin crew doing what they
normally do which is they kind of
crouched down don't they and they take
their hat off if they've got one on and
ask whether you want chicken or beef
that's normally what happens
we also learned that Harry can't begin
to understand why people might prefer
Catherine the Princess of Wales who of
course never complains never explains
and just does her Duty
this is how I was coming for her this is
how it's cover her if you don't see the
difference and understand why it's being
reported that way why then I can't help
you
I can't I'm sorry I just can't I mean
you sound like a blithering lunatic
don't you Harry
I can't help you
really well let me help you there were a
gazillion critical stories about Kate
long before your beloved Megan came
along had nothing to do with Kate's skin
color
and the Megan criticism had nothing to
do with her skin color
at all nothing to do with it she just
started doing things along with you
which were rankly hypocritical and in
some cases downright unpleasant and you
both got called out for it and you don't
like being criticized you think if
anyone criticizes you they're
automatically bullies and racists but
they're not in fact one of the people
has been accused of bullying is Meghan
Markle by several of her Pas at the
palace who had to sign ndas so they
couldn't tell the truth I'm sure that
Meghan Markle and Harry who want the
truth to come out
would like those ndas to be lifted and
maybe they should say so publicly so we
can hear from those Pas who I know at
least one of them was regularly reduced
to tears
by The Bullying from Meghan Markle and
if Megan doesn't think she did bully of
course she can sue me because I've said
it now so come and sue me and let's take
it to court
all of this leaves a deeply unpleasant
taste
in the mouth doesn't it and again I say
simply where does it end how much damage
do they want to cause
they can't be allowed back to any Royal
events because they'll probably be wired
up and taped for the next series of
their thrilling life story so what do
they do
what does King Charles do about his own
son
does he cut him off does he strip him
with his titles this is his son
it's a Shakespearean tragedy unfurling
and I'm afraid when it comes to help I
think Prince Harry might be Beyond it
he's been manipulated
I think partly is down to him as well
into believing their genuine Freedom
Fighters
to see this institutional gaslighting
that happens
is there is extraordinary
um and that's why everything that's
happened to us
was always going to happen to us because
if you speak truth to power that's how
they respond
truth to power what are you talking
about
your Prince Harry the Duke of Sussex
once third in line to the throne it
doesn't get a lot more powerful than you
before you decant for your freedom
before you gave up any Royal Duty
but wanted to have your Royal cake and
eat it by keeping your title so you
could exploit them and make gazillions
of dollars in America to the highest
bidder and what do you do for that money
you trash your family
endlessly and you're going to keep doing
it as does your wife who trashes her own
family most of whom she's disowned
is this what happiness looks like Harry
really
you're happy
hating your entire family your wife
hating all hers apart from her mother
like many of the claims in the series
none of this Stacks up does it
were the claims of racism at the palace
but no evidence of who that person was
or what they actually said
apparently Megan she repeated this in
this new installment
was banned by somebody at the palace
from seeking help for her Suicidal
Thoughts think about that for a moment
who was that person are we still working
at the palace does that person exist
did somebody actually say to her you
might be feeling suicidal but it's bad
for the brand you can't get help and if
they did where was her husband in all
this where was Prince Harry Mr mental
health he never stops banging on about
it and about the need to get help and
yet when his own wife
apparently had Suicidal Thoughts he
didn't get a help
does that make any sense does that sound
even remotely plausible to you
because it doesn't to me
so that's where we are another tissue of
self-serving lies mostly I suspect we
don't know yet but most of it looks like
the Oprah interview just another load of
unsubstantiated smears designed to
portray them as victims it doesn't
really pass the master of fact checking
one minute that a beloved young couple
inspired a nation the next nation is
horribly racist out to throw Megan to
the walls in the very beginning the
attacks on the Press were so wicked that
she was hated and feared for her life
but also the entire plot against him was
because there were simply too popular
so they were hated and despised and too
popular and this was all apparently a
heroic fight for family privacy but we
have to learn about that fight in a
hundred million dollar reality TV show
that flaunts their young family and
boasts about the very public social
justice campaigns Harry and Megan take
their audience for fools they blame
everybody but themselves they present
even the most incendiary of planes with
no evidence and sadly the impact
is real the royal family is getting
damaged the monarchy is getting
tarnished people are believing including
Beyonce it appeared from this series
they're believing that the royal family
are a bunch of callous races well
they're not I know the royal family a
lot of them well and they're not callous
races and they're Furious about this and
their right to be furious
okay well let's get into debating this
um I feel strongly about it I make no
pretense about it I the longer this has
gone on the more the attacks have grown
in their ferocity the more that that you
have the knowledge that the other side
can't
fight back that's what I find so
reprehensible and Harry knows that he
knows they won't they're going to
maintain the stiff upper lip and dignity
which used to be what being a royal was
all about well I'm joined Now by my Pat
Paul burrow of course famous Royal
Butler uh Katie nickel one of the top
royal uh experts I suppose you are
aren't you and Paula Ron Adrian
um of course is here as well so let me
start with Paul Burrell Paul
we've talked a bit about this haven't we
um about this fracturing between William
and Harry
Harry's now gone on television and
called his brother William a bully that
bullied him out of the country
I made a number of other allegations
yeah is that a liar he had to go at the
queen and everything when you watched it
I mean my jaw was dropping that he was
literally taking them all down one by
one what was your Georgie
I was well I saw six hours of it and I
was a very saddened by all of it because
I realized that there's no way back now
for Harry he's abandoned his family he's
abandoned his duty and he's abandoned
his country and he he's disrespected his
grandmother's Legacy which is the
Commonwealth of countries which she
upheld all her all her uh through her
lifetime and you know you can't say
these things about your family and get
away with it and I don't think that
he'll ever be welcomed back here again I
think the British public will have
something to say about that and there
are certain things that came out in in
this interview which I totally didn't
agree with at all I mean he said that he
couldn't get to his grandmother he lived
literally a few hundred yards away from
her back door at Windsor Castle and
Frogmore Cottages he could have walked
up the hill gone through that door and
gone into his grandmother's sitting room
at any time and said granny I've got a
problem the Queen's door was always open
it doesn't matter about what the
courtiers say the queen would say I'm
your grandmother Harry I love you you
can come and talk to me if you have a
problem so Harry you're trying to pull
the wool over our eyes I know better
than that and the meeting at Sandringham
yes you did attend that and in that
meeting apparently Harry said to his
grandmother I'd like to stay in the
royal family and wear my uniforms and
have my Army contacts and then go back
to America and do my commercial
campaigns and the queen quite rightly
said Harry you can't have one foot in
the camper one foot out because that's
not fair to the rest of the royal family
who can't do these commercial deals who
who just do their Duty for the country
so you can't have your cake and eat it
and quite rightly the Queen the queen
herself said no yeah and so Harry went
back so he had a digger herd in the
Netflix series whilst knowing that yes
she'd recently lost Prince Philip and
that she herself was in very ill health
and has now died sadly you know the
timing of all this above Buffalo else is
so reprehensible Paula Ron Adrian look
you've always defended
hang on a sec yes I always defended
Harry yeah I'll come back to you ball
I'm talking to Paula just quickly about
this you've always defended them
surely when you watch that latest stuff
today
watching anybody take down their brother
their father their grandmother
on television
it's not a good thing
it's not a good thing but I have always
said to you peers that this is only
going to get worse unless we stop and
start listening what you are witnessing
are people who believe that they have
been treated badly whether you believe
them or not whether you want to shout at
them or not whether you want to deny
them or not whether we want whether you
want us to listen to 12 minutes of you
telling us how awful they are as human I
think they are awful but that may well
be your opinion but you're here to give
me yours right I'm different yeah and
what is happening so I mean you're
entitled to say whatever you want well
of course and so are they and so are
they yes and that is what they are doing
that is what they feel they have been
they can say what they like they do when
they do what they do but when they do
what they do we are entitled in this
country when our country is put under
attack like this and branded a racist
country by these two
with a racist royal family of the head
of it we are entitled to defend we want
this country know about the Institute
that is the royal family we've seen what
happens when somebody calls out a member
of the royal household and says that
they are racist what happens to them
well they have to stop working they have
to close who is racist uh well we know
that there was the incident with Miss
with Lady Hussey no forget that
lady hussy she was removed from office
within 24. we won't forget she was
removed the moment because she was made
accountable of what who was racist and
Megan and Harry it could have been lady
hustle you don't know that you don't
know do you it could have been they said
he was a member of the family it could
have been somebody else and so what
we're doing we're told is could be any
of them so they're all all Smith by
association and as I've said we can keep
shouting but the fact is they are
hurting and we are witnessing that
you say they're counting their money
yeah I mean look you're not criticizing
Mike Tyndall for being on I'm a
celebrity are you or doing adverts with
Amazon or dominoes or whoever it is he's
doing is not a paid up member of the
royal family he doesn't get anything
from the wrong from the tax base not now
what they've done earn money no no hang
on they've given up Royal Duty and
they've left the country in the family
but what they haven't given up is the
Royal titles which now make them all the
money what I was just about to say the
point of Royal titles they listen they
are entitled to have their opinion if
they absolutely
hate The Establishment they hate well
they've left Britain right they've stood
down as working Royals and I think there
is a real issue with them holding on to
those titles very clear to see from
everything that we've seen in Netflix
that without that Royal calling card
there is nothing that no one is no one
is actually interested in what they have
to say about anything else
if they hate the institution so much if
it's racist and bigoted and alienated
and everything else then do what they
actually said night and this was new
because this was one of the new things
that did come out of today they offered
to return those titles if their version
of a half in half out monarchy didn't
work so they put that offer on the table
if they have a shred of dignity left put
that offer back on the table and follow
why would you want to be in a racist
institution so why would why would a
black police officer want to be part of
of the police Metropolitan Police why
would a black female fire often want to
be a part of the London Fire why do they
want to be the Lord do it you do it
they are in pain
causing pain they're inflicting Pains
come on there's more they're the ones
doing all the abuse victim blaming this
is a classic when you blame it back and
look at what's happening they're not
victims what you are hearing and what
I'm hearing is an app absolute tsunami
of denial denial denial
anything that comes out of their mouth I
don't believe it so I want to hear you
say that absolutely everything that has
come out of Harry and Megan's mouth is a
lie I think a lot of it is actually yeah
if there is some if there is some truth
in what they've got to say should we not
be worried
today which I thought completely sum
them up there was Tyler Perry for some
random reason he'd never met them
decides to give him his Mansion so
they're living in this vast Mansion
during the covert pandemic which you
think they might feel lucky about but no
no they're moaning away about that too
and Tyler Perry uh is talking over
footage and saying they've been abused
by their status in the royal family and
the footage shows a sneaky Paparazzi
craning down from a rooftop taking
pictures of them with their child only
it wasn't a Paparazzi it was a royal
photographer who had been accredited and
approved by them to take those pictures
on an official tour so it wasn't what it
seemed it was a lie they're the
producers of this series they know it's
a lie and they put it in there so that
people fall for this claptrap rather
like we saw the vast Army of Paparazzi
aiming at them at some event but it
wasn't it was a Harry Potter Premiere
they weren't even there it was five
years before he met Meghan Markle all of
it is smoke and mirrors and on the
really incendiary stuff no evidence who
is this person at the palace that said
to Meghan Markle I don't care that
you're feeling suicidal you don't get
any help why didn't Harry get her the
help if she was genuinely suicidal who
is the racist in the palace they still
won't tell us these are serious
allegations causing serious damage to
our royal family and this country's
reputation and it's not good enough that
they keep going on television spray
gunning everybody again and they don't
give us the actual facts
have been incredibly Brave take him on
an Institute please do me if he wants to
take them down and you sit down two
institutions that I'm afraid that
they're trying to take down and this is
this is a blatant attempt to take down
but they won't succeed and I think the
Royal Family's dignity and maintaining
its silence and that show of
togetherness tonight is actually what
people want people I think people are
just switching off people to believe
that they're all family are keeping a
dignified silence we know that that's
not true well then we learned a few
weeks
[Music]
the articles in the newspapers it always
references the source
of sauce
I've got to leave it there final
question just to Paul before we let you
go Paul you've been around the royal
family a very long time what will the
royal family be feeling about all this
there'll be appalled by all of this
washing dirty laundry in public it's not
their scene and they will close ranks
they will hold it together with dignity
and you're quite right that's what we
expect them to do
um don't attack Kate and William because
they are our future king and queen right
case has never put a foot wrong don't
attack her she's she's the jewel in our
Crown right now and she deserves our
respect and admiration and had
unbelievable criticism early on actually
which everyone can be actually against
you don't see any of that in the series
it's all just about negative for Megan
positive for Kate total lies absolute
lies no thank you fasten your seat belts
though we've got the book to come right
or 400 Pages
this never stops right thank you Katie
good to see you thank you Paula always
good to hear the other view uh I don't
agree with it but I respect your right
to have it I hope I'm just going to well
still to come tonight and look at the
division it causes here as well they've
launched a load of Divisions was Meghan
Markle made a scapegoat for the raw Rift
or were the fault lines when Harry and
William there already we'll debate that
next and we're going to have a nurse who
helped say Boris Johnson's life and is
now striking in protest against the
conservative government that's exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello
hello
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back it's another fiery
show because this is the subject that
gets people's passions fired up what's
becoming clear is that Meghan Markle is
definitely not alone in her delusional
victimhood Harry seems even more bitter
and twisted about it all and wants us to
think he's an even bigger victim in his
relationship with his brother William is
now likely torched beyond all repair
well where did it all go wrong according
to the Sussex version of events their
truth which is very rarely the truth
says that Meghan Markle was scapegoated
by the palace because she was get this
too popular whilst at the same time
being so criticized
I think Australia was a real turning
point because they were so popular
so popular with the public
the internals at the palace were
incredibly threatened by that she's
becoming a royal rock star figure I
would argue as a couple than William
McKay that's probably not a good thing
in the long term it's a dirty game
you know there's leaking but there's
also planting of stories you just see it
play out like a story about someone in
the family would pop up for a minute and
think we've got to make that go away
but there's real estate on a website
homepage there is real estate there on a
newspaper front cover and something has
to be filled in there about someone
Royal
I've seen little cartoons of me on all
fours with her I'm holding a dog lead
and me wearing the dog collar how
predictable that you know the woman is
to be blamed for the decision of a
couple in fact it was my decision she
never asked to leave
I was the one that had to see it for
myself but it's misogyny at its best
all door might say that kind of thing
don't they well joining me now the
author and historian Tessa Dunlop
journalist and columnist Maureen Karen
because upon the former conservative
Minister who gets a mention in the
series uh Anne whittaken welcome to all
of you or in Canada what is the view in
America about us I'm hearing a worrying
number of Americans falling for this
claptrap including it turns out Beyonce
who sent this ridiculous text message to
Meghan Markle after the Oprah winathon
now saluting her courageous brilliant
stand against well we've got to hear I
think
Beyonce just texted
really much
shut up just checking in
he's checking in just casual nice okay
she knows who I am
no it's okay she said
she wants me to feel safe and protected
she admires and respects my bravery and
vulnerability and she thinks I was
selected to break generational curses
that need to be healed
um
that's what I said yeah even the dog is
calling [ __ ] on that uh Maureen
um what do you think what do you make of
this what does America make of this do
most rational Americans see through this
oh Piers yes please again let me
reassure you Beyonce would be in the uh
minority opinion of these two I think we
are all
well and thoroughly exhausted by this
endless moaning and whinging and banging
on you know and the hurling of vague
accusations I mean all this time later
all of these podcasts and interviews and
now this six-parter and a book to come
and we still have no Smoking Gun what
are they waiting for
well there is no smoking gun is there or
we would have heard it by now
um
endless rehashing of the same old wines
they're they're very very very in love
with their grievances their victimhood
it's a very strange psyche they seem to
share you know you were talking earlier
about you know is how much Harry may be
to blame but I really think in Megan he
found someone to really unlock I think
years of rage and resentment and
jealousy because this is like a tsunami
it just keeps coming and coming and
coming and the constant comparison to
his mother actually I found I've got to
say pretty distasteful because in my
estimation having known them both both
women no comparison whatsoever is valid
between Meghan Markle and Princess Diana
and Diner's Fame was stratospherically
bigger as was the attention that was
afforded to it all right you've been
seething and waiting to get stuck into
me all night come on I mean you do you
are the tangible proof that this is a
dirty green because you helped make it
carrying on spreading the muck all
around like a little kid who's done a
poo and wants to look at it
calm down actually it's then the
spreading the mug they're the only
members of the royal family doing any of
the talking they're the ones on all the
TV stations and TV series and podcasts
and books spray gunning their family our
royal family our monarchy and my country
Britain running is a bunch of callous
races come on they are the ones
spreading the dirt deep off your
patriotic chest
I'm going to explain to you they've made
it very clear that actually I thought
they were very coded and careful when
they called out rarely incidentally you
have to sit through a long three hours
to find any specifics on William or
Charles they're very careful to Target
most of it at the fourth estate
particularly the Associated Press which
they had a victory over in the courts
well it was settled and and then then
they won the appeal Harry Potter Harry
claimed that Daily Mail was was actually
responsible for his wife's miscarriage
without providing a shred of evidence
that that was true I send you that line
off there that was a classic case of a
vulnerable man who's fighting a
difficult case
two and two together an equaling fight
or revengeful vindictive man who
actually says he hates the press and
media attention but has just invaded the
privacy of his family in spectacular
fashion because a a streaming platform
has paid him a hundred million dollars
there's a word for that and it is
hypocrisy what he did was call out and
he referred to it as the symbiotic
relationship between the press and the
royal family he is well within his
rights to do that and we're winning our
rights to judge the reason that I feel
Keen tonight to hold you to account sure
is that as we heard in that documentary
you were a big player a giant mouthpiece
for literally stirring or if I made [ __ ]
stirring Harry and Megan are bigger than
Kate and William oh that's gonna say
stable I think oh let's just throw in a
match and watch it blow up that's what
you did you're like the kid with his
finger in the diet waiting wiggling till
the flood comes calm down
I'm not gone you don't have to be calm
I'm just saying if you can't I can
respond which is to say that up to the
point they got married I was very
supportive of them including on their
wedding day writing a very very
supportive piece for the mail on Sunday
actually about how brilliant it was to
see a biracial wedding finally in the
royal family it was only when their
behavior changed when they became a
Serial pair of Hypocrites wanting their
Royal cake and eating it preaching about
stuff they did the complete opposite
with that I turned against it let's go
let's get out of my own ridiculum and
you get mentioned in the series were you
expecting that and what was your
reaction
honestly appears it gave me the greatest
belly laugh that I've had since Neil
kinnick fell in the sea I mean it was
unbelievable I
I made an adverse comment about Megan on
Celebrity Big Brother now as you know
Celebrity Big Brother you're completely
cut off from the rest of the world you
know I hardly had the palace on the
phone and apparently the fact that I had
made this comment which was my own
genuine opinion uh is all part of it's
It's proof of that the conspiracy uh
that there was uh to
discreditious my own opinion let's watch
the clip actually for the viewers who
didn't see it let's watch the clip from
Celebrity Big Brother
but there's real estate on a website
homepage There's real estate there on a
newspaper front cover and something has
to be filled in there about someone
Royal what do we all think about Meghan
Markle I love Nick I think she's very
beautiful no I love it okay let's take
the boat I think he's trouble why do you
think she's trouble man
um
attitude I I worry she's older than him
yeah
she's been married before yeah
I added all up and I'm uneasy there we
go
well you weren't wrong were you Ann
whitakam um because she was she's a lot
older than Harry five years older she's
a divorcee the last husband heard it was
all over I think when she sent the Rings
back in the mail
um and she comes barreling into the
royal family picks up her handsome
prince and before we know it drags him
back to California to turn into a money
machine and they disown both their
families that I would say that is the
person personification of trouble
well absolutely as I say 10 out of 10
for prophecy on my part uh but I think
it's very clear what's gone on uh Megan
wants the lifestyle of an A-list
celebrity but she's never risen above
um apart uh in a TV soap opera uh and uh
Harry uh wants all the trappings of
royalty without actually uh the slog of
the duty that goes with it and that's
what they want
um and that's what you know all this is
about it's about making money from the
only thing that they've got which is
their Royal connections for nothing else
they've got nothing else make money they
are sort of attacking an institution
that you exploit for personal gain it's
quite breathtaking I'm going to leave it
there thank you to my panel a lively
debate thank you Tessa we'll get you
back don't worry you can hold your
horses to the next barrage you give me
uh well next one night nurses have
walked out the biggest strike of its
kind in NHS history the nurse who helps
say boy Johnson's life is one of them
and she's here exclusively to tell me
why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh on Central we
clapped we clanged and we banged for
them as they risked their lives for us
working on the covered Wards and grossly
inadequate PPE two years on for the
first time in history tens of thousands
of nurses are on the picket line
striking of a pay Royal College of
Nursing boss said that she was truly
sorry for taking the strike action
well joining me now is Jenny McGee who's
the intensive care nurse who looked
after and helped save the life of our
former prime minister Boris Johnson when
he was admitted to ICU with covid-19
um Jenny it's great to see I remember
obviously what happened and it was a
extraordinary moment for the country as
we all sort of waited and you were part
of a team which helped save him and
thank you for that it was a great
service he did the country
um now you're going on strike in a way a
protest against the conservative
government whose leader at the time you
helped save his life why are you going
on strike what does it mean so much to
you feel you have to do this
I think
um there's just a real concern for
what's happening in our profession
um we are terribly terribly understaffed
we have 50 000 vacancies across this
country and we are seeing that on the
wards we're seeing that when we're
working we do not have enough nurses on
our wards
um we feel that nurses are leaving the
profession in droves because why are
they leaving do you think I think
they're leaving because we've had enough
we have so much pressure and
responsibilities put in our shoulders
we are busy every single shift we can't
give that care that we so desperately
want to give and we are we feel that
we're underpaid we as I say we have a
lot of responsibility on our shoulders
we care very deeply about the patients
that we look after and but we just want
to be paid a fair wage I completely
agree with you and I would always
support nurses up and down the country I
think you're a fantastic group of people
and I think there's a horrible hypocrisy
for those who are out applauding you
every Thursday as you're literally
risking your lives and then now would
oppose your right to a fair pay rise I
think that's ridiculous the question is
I guess how much in the end would
constitute a fair rise I don't think 19
pay rise for any people in the country
right now are sustainable
and it sets the precedent for the other
Industries obviously as well what do you
think I mean inflation's running about
10 right now what do you think would be
a fair reasonable final settlement
personally from my point of view I think
a pay rise which is fair in terms of
inflation so I think 19 is not out of
the question because we have worked so
incredibly hard throughout the pandemic
and we have proved ourselves time and
time again but we just want something
that we can live on that's in line with
inflation we're not asking for Millions
we're just asking for a few a fair wage
what does it do to you when you feel
underpaid undervalued overworked
understaffed under huge pressure yeah
what is what toll does that take on you
as a human being incredible child
because all we really want to do is give
wonderful care to the patients that
we're looking after that's what we're in
the profession to do that's why we're
nurses we want to look after people we
want to make them better and when you
have all these external things coming in
and interfering with that it's
demoralizing it's so tough and I quit my
job a year or two ago because of all
those pressures that I had on me I felt
I couldn't do it anymore here in the UK
and I needed a break and that's what's
happening to many many nurses and what
made you come back
well I have a life here in London so I
took a break and I went abroad for a
year I went home to New Zealand spent
lots of time with my family but I have a
life here
um and
um you know now you work in various
hospitals well yeah as an ICU nurse an
intensive care but I don't have a
permanent job I pick up work day to day
so I have control over when I want to
work do you feel any qualms about
strikes first-time nurses have gone on
strike obviously you deal with people's
lives do you feel qualms about doing
this on the morality side of it I mean
we haven't gone into this with no
thought
um and the strike days were planned and
a lot of thought went into how we were
going to strike we in the hospitals we
still had intensive care staffed
emergencies so a lot of thought went
into how we were going to do it and I
think but I think it was necessary we
need people to take note well I think
the NHS is creaking at the seams and the
only people propping it up people like
you and I thank you for your service I
think it's amazing the job that you do
and you were brought into public
attention by what happened with Boris
Johnson but actually you do that every
day when you're in the hospital in the
united units saving all sorts of people
most of whom are not leaders of
countries so thank you and I hope that
you get the pay rise you deserve I want
to bring in now another nurse we're
going to call it Anna she wants to
remain anonymous but we'll say where she
is a nurse but she's an experienced NHS
nurse who has reservations about these
strikes doesn't feel comfortable so I'm
going to call you Anna and to tell me
why you don't agree with this with the
strikes
um hi sir
strike right and demand whatever they
want but I think the demand is for the
third pay what exactly is fair how we're
gonna Define fair and every time the
inflation will change and are we going
to go on strike every time that's
endless and I think instead of striking
against I mean about our pay we should
ask to stop the waste of money in NHS
and then we would have the money for all
the pay rise and for everything else we
need this is where I think we should be
focusing on not yeah I mean I do think
you know if I was a nurse right now I'd
be looking at all the money that was
squandered on PPE that didn't work uh
testing systems that didn't work you
know contracts to companies therefore I
said all of whom made
fortunes out of stuff that just didn't
work in the pandemic and I'd be thinking
well we found the money for all that
suddenly when we had to where is that
money money actually for the people who
are in the coal phase every day
exactly and another
and before pandemic what about wastage
of medication how many times patient is
prescribed medication and giving a full
dose for for a certain amount of time
and actually stopped in the middle and
the medication is being wasted it
doesn't go anywhere and and thousands of
thousands of pounds is being just thrown
away what about other things I don't
know sticker posters
I did when when you're walking on the
world you can see thousands of pounds
being just flushed down it must be you
know it must be enraged
I also feel strongly about I I
absolutely despise the fact that nurses
in this country and doctors still have
to pay for parking outside hospitals I
think it's a complete and utter disgrace
that you go in to save people's lives
and we charge you for the honor of
parking outside the hospitals it is a
total total disgrace that shames this
country uh I've got to leave it there
Anna thank you for calling in uh keep up
the great work I know that you know you
all basically I think share the concerns
it's really about how you get to where
you want to get to which is to be valued
properly so I thank you for joining me
thank you so much thank you and thank
you again Jenny I appreciate it well
coming next uh Donald Trump promised a
major announcement today it's proved to
be a major or weird disappointment to
find out why with tonight's pack that's
coming up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back I'm glad to be joined by
tonight's Pat Richard Tyson Isabel Oak
shot always has a little bit of spice to
the pack you two
um nurses strike you said a very
interesting thing on the break which I
didn't know that the nurse has got a 30
pay rise back in the early 70s so in the
early 70s actually there was significant
industrial action everywhere and the
nurses were they were striking they were
marching all over London so you know
there is a track record of industrial
action but look the reality is the
government have handled this appallingly
since the end
what I put for what they should do
because there's a there's a staffing
crisis in healthcare in Social care they
should say for three years knowing no
basic rate income tax for any healthcare
workers on the front line including
ambulance workers and you pay for it
about six billion quid by not paying the
bank of England shouldn't be paying
interest to the city banks that have
already very wealthy they don't need it
other central banks are not doing that
that would pay for it that's how you
attract and retain and and get people
and the other way is about you could
I've always thought there's an argument
to have an extra attack of a penny for
everybody specifically for the NHS and
social care I mean that's been done
before
but the NHS need
money personally I'm a view of the view
that the money that's in it needs to be
better were you both tweeted about this
extraordinary Story the NHS foundation
in the Midlands in Stafford advertising
for a hundred and fifteen thousand pound
a year job as a director of lived
experience I mean what even is what does
that mean well I I this is like Meghan
markers
it's not true but I've lived I've got a
lived experience so I'm going to just
spout on about it but the truth is you
wouldn't qualify for that job actually
because you have to be a strategically
talented and I'm not sure the bridge
builder is here but it is but this is
the trouble is you read that you think
well that's where all the money's going
well completely look I found that job
advert quite easily by looking on
websites for NHS jobs that pay over six
figure salaries and that's the first
thing I alighted upon and I don't know
what it is and I put it to the
employment Minister and he had no idea
what it was either so look I think that
we could free up an awful lot of money
by cutting jobs that are completely
meaningless and a load of the diversity
inclusion that's low hanging fruit
there's tons of other stuff divert that
money what would you give the nurses
it's really difficult to put a figure
out but I think it has to be substantial
I really do the problem is with 10
inflation substantial means you've got
to start at 10 otherwise you're
basically giving them nothing I don't
have a problem with that because but
what about all the other all the other
people who want their money you can't
give them all even inflation I don't
think right you can't keep inflating
this you know out of existence you've
got to reduce taxes you've got to lift
it up from the bottom up that's the way
you put more money more money into
people's net pay packets is it true that
thanks to incompetent government notably
by Liz truss and quasi-grading we simply
don't have the money to do what we'd
like to do with what institutions well
there's there's many many reasons we
don't have the money one of which is the
risk not the pandemic but the response
to the pandemic and the billions that
were squandered on ridiculous things you
mean by by the health secretary Matt
Hancock well I certainly mean that
there's some of the contracts
well as you know I didn't write
absolutely everybody I know just apart
from Matt Hancock yeah surprising that
isn't it I mean after all it was his
book so he probably wasn't going to
blame himself in anything the waste of
money is obscene everywhere but the
reality is in terms of health spending
per capita we are bang on the oecd
average so we're not under spending on
Health Care the truth is we're spending
it badly too many middle management I
would let the nurses run the wards I go
back to the old school matrons right
you're in charge of the money and you're
in charge of the patient care get on
with it because they know how to spend
the money better than some manager
sitting in a suit in a corner well there
are also very good models in America the
Cleveland Ohio has the doctors running
everything right um so you actually
don't have managers that don't
understand Healthcare maybe we need a
superhero to run the NHS like Donald
Trump who of course is his new uh
attempt to get in the bag of the White
House is falling down in flames
according to polls so we've now
Unleashed his new nft range of himself
as a superhero in eight different guises
and about the 45 000 of these and you
can you can get your own Trump superhero
NFD making your planet great again where
are your ones it's given me an idea
actually exactly is Trump is Trump done
yeah I think he's done I think he loses
assuming he runs he loses in the
primaries to Rhonda sounds yeah no
question at all I think America wants
something different and I think if Brian
runs again to Santa's wins quite easily
easily hands down you agree I I do
actually I think he looks tired I think
he looks like yesterday's man and I
think it's an impossible mountain to
climb yeah also American I think it's
just had enough yeah of two old guys
they just seen it done it want to move
on thank you Pat Uh whatever you're up
to tonight Keep It Uncensored let's look
for a delight good night
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]